[Music]
ha
you should have seen the look on your
face
oh my god ainsley try not to get
scared challenge no i'm not running out
of ideas
so i scared you pretty good i know now
it's your turn
to scare me and see if you can scare me
luckily i'm pewdiepie i never get scared
so this should be a pretty easy
challenge don't you think
i tweeted out for you guys to scare me
now let's see how it went
all right first link oh my god
oh my god it's sleeping
it's just gonna jump scare me
hey leafy here
hello
i knew it was coming i knew it was going
to happen
it still i mean it didn't scare me oh
look who got scared
wait what the [ __ ] is this ainsley
are you are you a kinder egg
wow wow guys i i really gotta say uh
whoa
oh oh god tone it down a bit because i
i'm getting a little bit too scared
right now
jesus christ is that markiplier
oh my god
god damn it ah
[ __ ] sake
my beautiful
all right what do we got here
great a plus so far what is this
[Music]
no
that poor kitty no he's getting
triggered
[Music]
okay i got it working
what's wrong oh that's creepy
that was a good good five second clip
all right i got it working
what's wrong
i think you didn't need the screen part
that was pretty cool that's pretty
what the you guys are just showing off
your [ __ ] pet
okay this looks pretty scary
[Music]
goddammit
you guys suck you guys [ __ ] suck okay
oh no i've seen this
no why did i watch this [ __ ] anime as
a kid
the expressions in it so horrifying i
never forget it
they always scream so much too i don't
you know i'd rather watch boko no pico
than this [ __ ] [ __ ] i swear to god
oh
i remember shion she used to be nice and
then in another
oh episode didn't go off
[Applause]
oh sexual undertones a plus japan
what the [ __ ]
it gets me every time [ __ ] higarashi
man why did i [ __ ] watch that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what's wrong with me scare pewdiepie
season 3 coming up right there what the
[ __ ]
oh well i'm glad it wasn't scary jesus
christ i didn't know
snakes had buttholes i mean it
it should have been obvious but now i
know
oh god what is this
oh it's a cat oh oh it really scared me
that one
jeez a father puts up cameras in his
house when his daughter told him
20 000 retweets
i've never seen this
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] papers man
i'm starting to regret this video oh god
not the [ __ ] snakes
i didn't realize i had a thing for
snakes until i saw snake
oh my god
[ __ ] you oh i've seen this one this is a
made by some swedish uh people and
they made a full movie out of it called
lights out it's not bad
but i prefer the short film
it's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] man
just stop just stop doing that listen if
i saw a disgusting naked ass i would be
scared like that as well
you just got beamed
[Music]
i nearly died what is this go to sleep
i dare you
great
[Music]
oh no
no
stop please stop
oh my god top of the morning two ladies
my name is jacksepticeye
[Music]
if i don't make it back tell the king
to help me
[Music]
ah